[Ukraїner
Експедиція]
[Київ,
Наддніпрянщина]
Існує великий рух створення креативних хабів
у колишніх індустріальних просторах.
У хабах створюються можливості
для освіти у сфері креативних індустрій,
[Михайло Глубокий
Директор з розвитку і комунікацій фонду «Ізоляція»]
... можливості для пошуку роботи
і робочі місця.
«IZONE», своєю чергою ...
Ця будівля — це коворкінг,
це організація різних подій:
це і лекції, і якісь воркшопи,
і це місце працює як простір для виставок.
Зазвичай це молоді художники,
у яких ще немає виставкового досвіду,
і для них є унікальна можливість виставитися
у великій, вже визнаній інституції.
І вони можуть це записати у своє портфоліо.
Це наше найбільше приміщення,
тут відбуваються всі великі події:
кінофестивалі, кінопокази, концерти,
конференції, величезні виставки.
Крім всього іншого,
на першому поверсі відбувається
проєкт «Вільний пульт» —
це проєкт із підтримки молодих
невідомих музикантів України.
Ми дуже раді, що тут залишилися
частини справжнього заводу.
Ця підлога — оригінальна підлога заводу.
Тут залишилися балки,
тут залишилися крани,
дуже великий індустріальний ліфт,
який відкривається в різні боки,
і можна завантажувати великі вантажі.
Усе це має дуже класний вигляд
і створює цю індустріальну
атмосферу справжнього заводу.
Вони іноді застрягають,
але, насправді, тут дуже весело
і всі вважають, що цей ліфт дуже
кінематографічний.
Ми відкрили коворкінг 2015 року,
і відтоді він тільки росте.
Зростає попит.
Зараз тут працює багато людей.
Усі вони займаються творчими проєктами.
Тут є люди, які займаються кіно,
анімацією, рекламою,
фото, архітектурою, урбаністикою.
У нас декілька команд та незалежних художників,
які тут працюють.
[Марина Самохіна
Координаторка майстерні шовкодруку в «Izone»]
Моє завдання — влаштувати такі процеси,
щоб нам разом було легше діяти, ніж поодинці.
Ми проводимо воркшопи з друку,
а також принтвечірки в дуже різних форматах:
і в майстерні, і поза нею.
Це — наше ком'юніті.
[сміється]
Фонд «Ізоляція» — це платформа
культурних ініціатив,
яка була створена 2010 року в Донецьку
на території заводу ізоляційних матеріалів.
Звідти пішла назва.
Ми багато речей робили першими.
Узагалі вся ця ідея ревіталізації
індустріальних просторів,
великий такий проєкт був в Донецьку вперше.
Це був унікальний для України досвід,
якого до цього ні у кого не було.
Ми всі відчували, що є на
найбільш гострому місці життя міста,
що ми можемо змінити його,
можемо на нього впливати.
У 2011 році була створена перша резиденція
на заводі «Ізоляція»
для художників зі всієї України.
Куратори приїжджали в Донецьк,
дивилися на контекст,
розуміли якусь тему, яка притаманна місцю.
І відразу інституція стала таким місцем,
де люди розуміли, що тут говорять про нас,
говорять про наші проблеми,
і про те, що відбувається навколо нас.
Було дуже багато людей,
всі хотіли дізнатися про мистецтво:
що в Україні відбувається,
що у світі відбувається.
Був дуже величезний попит.
У 2014 році...
[підбирає слова]
Я просто...
Ну, так складно.
Насправді, 2014 року вже була захоплена
Донецька обласна державна адміністрація,
в центрі міста були блокпости,
багато людей зі зброєю і т.д.
Ми намагалися продовжувати свої активності,
тому що знали, що людям це потрібно.
Ми зробили великий фестиваль
української літератури.
Це тривало тиждень, було дуже багато людей.
У нас просто вся «Ізоляція» була забита публікою.
Ми у такий спосіб показали собі,
і, як нам здавалося, іншим,
що ці люди в центрі,
які там захоплюють і кричать,
що вони хочуть у Росію,
що їх мало і що це — не Донецьк.
9 червня на територію «Ізоляції»
прийшли озброєні люди,
у них був папір про те,
що ця територія тепер належить їм,
що вони будуть її використовувати для того,
щоб зберігати гуманітарну допомогу з Росії.
У принципі, ніхто з нас тоді
не був вдома і не повертався.
Наскільки ми знаємо,
у всіх приміщеннях зараз —
військова база «ДНР» і в'язниця.
Це така секретна спецв'язниця,
якої немає в жодних офіційних документах.
Це просто закрита катівня,
де катують людей, де вбивають людей.
Ніхто не знає скільки там людей,
ніхто не знає, що там відбувається.
Туди, звісно, не пускають
ніякий Червоний Хрест, нікого.
Ми зверталися до Червоного Хреста.
Вони сказали, що не можуть
отримати доступ до цих приміщень.
Єдине, що ми можемо дізнатися про це, —
це з інтерв'ю людей, яких обміняли
або чомусь відпустили,
і вони про це розповідають.
Я, якщо чесно, переживала всі ці події в шоці.
Нічого не розуміла, що відбувається,
я не могла ніколи,
до найостаннішого моменту мені не здавалося,
що таки дійде до війни.
Оскільки я була в команді, то я...
Для мене це досить... Я...
Я не впевнена, як би я
це все відсвічувала наодинці,
а в команді — пережила.
[знічено сміється]
Донецьку «Ізоляція» давала якесь
альтернативне бачення для звичайних людей,
хто був спроможний це відчувати.
У Києві з'явився новий контекст,
треба було переосмислити все, що ми робимо
і що тепер будемо робити.
Ми надаємо можливість і майданчик для
різноманітних художніх, культурних проєктів.
Місія «Ізоляції» — це розвиток України
за допомогою культури і мистецтва.
Ми сподіваємось, що ми зможемо створити
копії IZONE у маленьких містах,
і особливо, що для нас важливо, на Сході України.
«Ізоляція» працює не лише в Києві,
а і по всій Україні.
Багато проєктів відбувається в Донецькій області,
в Луганській області.
І ми збираємо всі книжки, які можливо,
про Донбас, Донецьк, Луганськ,
про історію, про те, що зараз відбувається,
про те, що там, можливо,
буде в майбутньому.
У 2014 році році був створений
проєкт «Донбаські студії» —
це бібліотека, це дослідження і публічна програма.
[Дмитро Чепурний
Куратор проєкту «Донбаські студії»]
Вагомою частиною публічної програми
є літня школа —
це міжнародна велика резиденція.
Подія, яка об'єднує дослідників,
художників, кураторів і активістів.
Зараз ми дуже багато фокусуємося
на резиденціях у малих містах на Донбасі.
Ми займалися резиденціями в Покровську,
Маріуполі, Краматорську,
у Бахмуті, Старобільську.
Артрезиденція — це взагалі один
з ключових для «Ізоляції» напрямів...
[Катерина Іголкіна
Менеджерка з комунікацій фонду «Ізоляція»]
... тому що вони дають можливість
обмінюватись досвідом,
не тільки у межах України,
а й закордонним досвідом.
Тому що ми запрошуємо на резиденції
іноземних художників,
і вони потім створюють свої проєкти,
які ми також можемо презентувати тут.
[англійською] Я — художник із Нью-Йорка,
[Клеменс Пул
Художник, мистецький куратор]
[англійською]
я працюю з «Ізоляцією» близько п'яти років.
[англійською] Мої інтереси збігаються з тим,
чим ми тут займаємось.
[англійською] Ця робота передбачає чимало
викликів, і мені вони подобаються.
[англійською] Вперше я приїхав [в Україну]
відразу після Майдану,
[англійською] і я думаю, що відтоді все змінилося:
[англійською] молодіжна культура, галереї,
виставки — все стало набагато цікавішим,
[англійською]  різноманітнішим і покращується далі.
[англійською] Мистецькі інституції, як «Ізоляція»,
здатні робити справді цікаві речі,
[англійською] і можуть зображати те,
що відбувається зараз.
[англійською] І я вважаю,
що це перевага цих інституцій.
«Ізоляція» є невід'ємною частиною
культурного ландшафту,
який формується поступово
і на Сході України, і загалом в Україні.
Частина цієї бібліотеки —
це бібліотека «Гуртобусу», яка подорожує.
Тут є книжки, які видані фондом «Ізоляція»,
наприклад, багато краєзнавчих книжок.
Це історія, це політика.
Тут — дизайн, тут — образотворче мистецтво,
українські каталоги митців.
Тобто люди в різних регіонах,
там, де ми маємо події,
вони можуть, наприклад,
теж погортати ці книжки.
Люди дуже відгукуються, читають.
[англійською] Що ми робимо?
Ми їздимо по всій Україні,
[англійською] зупиняємось у різних
маленьких містах і селах
[англійською] та проводимо культурні події.
[англійською] Сучасне мистецтво — про те,
щоб замислюватися над речами.
[англійською] Це про переосмислення того,
що ти бачиш у світі.
[англійською] І я думаю, що цей проєкт
вдало прокомунікував це.
[англійською] Всі програми мають певні елементи,
що залучають громаду,
[англійською] де ми скоріше ставимо питання,
ніж даємо відповіді.
[англійською] Метою цього проєкту
є ідея децентралізації культури:
[англійською] працювати з громадою,
яка буває непоміченою
[англійською] поряд із більшими
культурними тенденціями.
[англійською] І автобус — це найкращий транспорт,
щоб побачити людей по всій Україні.
Мені дуже подобаються програми
в маленьких містах.
Я була частиною проєкту «Гуртобус».
Після цих подорожей я дуже оптимістично
дивлюся на Україну, на молодь,
на якісь перспективи.
Було дуже багато корисних прикладів того,
як це відбувається в інших країнах,
коли цілі індустріальні райони перетворюються
на регіони культури, туризму.
Ми розробляємо програму
підтримки таких стартапів,
запрошуємо експертів,
які допомагають розробити програму,
розробити фінансовий план
для існування таких центрів.
І, я сподіваюсь, що їх стане тільки більше
у наступні декілька років.
У 2014 році здавалося, що зараз, зараз
ми повернемося,
тут кілька місяців пересидимо,
а зараз це уже складно собі уявити.
Але, звісно, ми — з Донецька,
ми маємо повернутись і щось там робити.
[Автор проєкту
Богдан Логвиненко]
[Продюсерка
Каріна Пілюгіна]
[Режисер
Микола Носок]
[Інтерв'юерка
Каріна Пілюгіна]
[Оператори
Михайло Шелест, Анна Воробйова]
[Режисерка монтажу
Марія Теребус]
[Субтитрувальниця
Оля Стулій]
[Ukraїner
Експедиція]
[USAID
Серія відео створена за підтримки Агентства США
з міжнародного розвитку (USAID)]